you don't have to like hit a very  specific note you can kind of talk about  anything serious goofy  and you you get comfortable  it's weird because most comedians you  see it are so uncomfortable with moments  without laughter sometimes mark norman  oh really comedy uh he's not  uncomfortable no he just can't help  himself with the one liner yeah yeah he  just zings uh it's got like he's got  like a file in his head that just comes  flying out guys it comes flying out yeah  i just did his podcast with uh with  samurail oh yeah yeah very fun uh we  might be drunk it's a great podcast yeah  um  but  you know you you see comics who also on  stage i mean obviously you want to get  laughs on stage but there's